dr strange and the multiverse of madness
is almost in theatres but what should
fans expect from a sam raimi mcu collab
and who is america chavez these
questions and more answered straight
ahead
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness premieres in theaters on may 6
2022. marvel head honcho kevin feige had
initially announced that the sequel was
set to release a year earlier but it
ended up getting delayed due to reshoots
and other production issues in addition
to covid19 interruptions thor love and
thunder and other upcoming phase 4
titles were also pushed back due to the
covert pandemic but multiverse of
madness had other setbacks including a
change in filmmakers in fact one source
told the hollywood reporter that new
director sam raimi and new writer
michael waldron were brought on to
essentially create a whole new movie
while mcu fans have been getting
impatient for the new doctor strange
vehicle those who enjoy the darker side
of cinema will likely be happier with
the end result as raymie and waldron
reportedly use their delayed timetable
to make the movie just a little bit more
scary
sam raimi is no stranger to either
superheroes or horror his previous work
includes the original spider-man trilogy
the evil dead trilogy and many other
horror films and comic inspired projects
in a 2022 empire interview kevin feige
explained that when searching for a
director their team thought scoring
raymie would be incredible but didn't
think there was any chance of it
happening however raymie ultimately
agreed to set up a meeting and the
enthusiasm he had for the project made
the choice a no-brainer on both sides
horror filmmaker scott derrickson who
directed the first doctor strange film
was originally going to return for the
sequel before leaving in january 2020
feige told empire we love scott and i
think scott feels the same nobody
believes it but it was just creative
differences neither marvel nor derekson
himself seemed to harbor any ill will
around this decision and both appear
excited to see the project come together
with raymie in the director's chair
there are many theories as to what might
be behind the problems with the
multiverse in the new doctor strange
film the ending of marvel's first disney
plus series one division which sees
wonder maxum math use chaos magic to
inadvertently rewrite reality revealed
that wonder's powers surpassed those of
the sorcerer's supreme and that it is
her destiny to destroy the world kevin
feige confirmed at the 2019 comic-con
panel that the events of one division
would tie directly into the new doctor
strange project and the trailers confirm
it i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview but then there's
loki another disney plush show in which
the protagonist's climactic
confrontation with he who remains aka
kang results in new branches of reality
splitting from the primary timeline
potentially allowing the multiverse to
take shape and of course there's doctor
strange himself who makes several
ill-advised decisions and spider-man no
way home beginning with a spell that
accidentally summons both
inter-dimensional villains and various
peter parkers the movie ends with
another spell that makes everyone forget
spider-man's secret identity strange
mind-wiping the entire human race seems
likely to have a dangerous outcome and
the trailers for multiverse of madness
certainly seem to indicate that he's
directly responsible for at the very
least opening the doorway between
universes
things just got out of hand
with wonder maximoff having officially
gained the moniker of the scarlet witch
fans have been eagerly awaiting the
return of elizabeth olsen to marvel's
big screen olsen was among a small group
of stars that were the first to confirm
their involvement in the dr strange
sequel leading to heaps of speculation
as to what her part in this story would
be most importantly would wonder be
among the film's heroes or its villain
the scarlet witch wields immense power
but has been given very little knowledge
on how to apply it though by the end of
one division she certainly seems to be
learning she has also suffered immense
loss both before and during the mental
breakdown that culminated in the
creation of the hex and her puppeting of
the people of west view wasn't exactly
the most morally upstanding of actions
wonders chaos magic is the stuff of myth
and legend a degree of power that could
potentially destroy her own reality and
possibly others she certainly appears to
be on the side of the angels in the
multiverse of madness trailer but there
are also numerous hints that she might
not stay there hopefully this won't be
wonder's final descent into darkness but
if it is at least we will get to see
olson go full evil
sochi gomez makes her marvel debut as
america chavez and multiverse of madness
and while we might not know much about
her exact role in the mcu we do have
some significant background information
on her character from the comics america
boasts superhuman strength speed and
durability as well as flight but her
signature power is the ability to open
star-shaped portals that allow her to
travel instantly across the multiverse
which makes sense considering the movie
in which she's being introduced she's
been a member of various incarnations of
the avengers as well as other teams like
the ultimates america originally
believed herself to have been born in an
extra-dimensional paradise called the
utopian parallel which was responsible
for giving her superpowers and which her
mothers sacrificed themselves to save
recently however this story is being
called into question with the appearance
of america's previously unknown sister
who told america that the utopian
parallel was actually a private island
research facility on earth and america's
powers are actually the result of
genetic experimentation
multiverse of madness will likely go
with the better known version of the
backstory but you never know regardless
america brings some much needed lgbtq
plus representation to the mcu as she is
a lesbian and appears to be sporting a
gay pride pin on her costume in the
trailers
in the official trailer for multiverse
of madness fans were quick to recognize
a familiar voice that of patrick stewart
who played professor charles xavier in
20th century fox's x-men film franchise
we should tell him the truth as the
founder of the x-men a comic book
property recently reclaimed by marvel
studios xavier's presence would be
explicit confirmation that mutants have
finally made their way to the mcu and
what better way to explain their arrival
than with multiversal shenanigans
stewart himself has been careful with
his words when asked about the upcoming
marvel project he told rolling stone all
i can say to you is we'll have to see
but bear in mind that professor xavier
has already died twice of course it
seems likely that stuart will be playing
an alternate universe version of the
character rendering those other deaths
moot in a recent interview with jake
hamilton however stewart seemed to
confirm its involvement in the upcoming
movie discussing the trailer stuart said
i actually didn't recognize my own voice
it sounded different whether i had a
cold or something at the time i don't
know he also recalled being astonished
that fans would realize it was him that
certainly makes it sound like stuart is
in the movie for sure whether he's
actually reprising his role as the
mutant master of telepathy remains to be
seen
in march 2019 after disney acquired 21st
century fox marvel studios obtained the
film rights to the x-men as well as a
fantastic four neither have yet been
integrated into the mcu but if patrick
stewart really is returning as charles
xavier the doors for the mutant's
arrival has potentially been kicked wide
open leading to all sorts of
possibilities eagle-eyed fans are also
quick to point out a possible easter egg
related to ryan reynolds deadpool in the
newest promotional poster for multiverse
of madness among the shards of glass
surrounding doctor strange there is one
that contains what looks like deadpool
doing his iconic shush pose while this
might just be the marvel team's way of
having some fun with the idea of the
multiverse this theory actually holds
some weight in 2021 kevin feige made
headlines when he confirmed that the
next deadpool film will be part of the
mcu
wait you're better than this
join us
use your powers for good heads up be a
superhero
in a brief shot during the multiverse of
madness trailer doctor strange is
handcuffed and escorted to a room by
ultron style robots once he reaches this
room there's a council of six
individuals seated before him this is
when viewers heard the voice of patrick
stewart and instantly connected the dots
on what the group likely is the
illuminati in the comics the illuminati
is a secret organization made up of some
of the most intelligent and powerful
individuals in the marvel universe the
original group was comprised of tony
stark charles xavier reed richards
stephen strange black bolt and neymar
but the roster has changed occasionally
over the years regardless the members of
the illuminati actors and elected
overseers of the superhuman world
sharing ideas and strategy on how to
govern super powered people despite
their conflicting aspirations if as
punishment for his desecration of
reality doctor strange really is being
brought before the illuminati it opens
up vast new worlds of possibility who
else will be a part of this organization
could we finally be getting an
introduction to the mcu's reed richards
could we be getting neymar or another
version of tony stark who's still alive
what role will the illuminati play in
the future of the mcu the second season
of loki for example and most importantly
would even multiverse of madness dare to
reference the ill-fated inhumans show
if we've learned anything from
spider-man no way home and loki is that
it can be quite disorienting to come
face to face with another version of
yourself the newest trailer for dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
seems to confirm the inclusion of many
variants of our lead protagonist
sinister strange will most likely prove
to be an adversary to our prime strange
and looks somewhat reminiscent of the
strange supreme of what if episode 4
defender strange is seen with striped
hair pulled back into a ponytail and
appears to be working alongside
america's chavez as a protector finally
zombie strange appears as an undead
version of the superhero strikingly
similar to the same character from
disney plus series what if there's also
at least one alternate version of wonder
shown confronting her other self in what
appears to be their wrecked west view
home this could be a sign of one just
consciousness breaking into two
following the traumatic events of one
division but a variance is probably more
likely the fact that there's a version
of wonder and street clothes confronting
their fully costumed scarlet witch
suggests the possibility of there being
an evil version of our wonder possibly
one that was corrupted by the darkhold
the end of one division saw wanda maxima
finally take her place as a scarlet
witch complete with iconic red suits and
magic powers however throughout the
multiverse of madness trailer there are
several changes made to her costume that
are hard to miss her red suit appears to
be growing darker bordering on black her
sleeves have now completely covered her
arms and there seems to be black at the
tips of her fingers similar to agatha
harkness when she used dark magic in one
division are these changes merely
ascetic or could they symbolize the
upcoming descent into darkness it should
also be noted that in the comics wonder
is a nexus being individuals described
as keystones of the multiverse with the
ability to affect probability and the
future this concept hasn't yet been
fully introduced to the mcu but there
have been some important hints
nexus
because the world doesn't revolve around
you
or does it
there's a lot we don't know but it's
clear that the scarlet witch is at the
very least going to be an important
player in the multiverse of madness
it's the overarching question hanging
above multiverse of madness who is the
ultimate villain of the story wonder
maxum off herself or a variant of her is
the obvious answer but there definitely
seems to be at least one evil doctor
strange in the trailer there's also kang
the conqueror of course who invented the
time-variance authority in order to
maintain the proper flow of the sacred
timeline and to promise that other
versions of himself would invade the
multiverse after his death another
possibility is c'thun the original
author of the darkhold in the comics who
also has a comic book connection to the
scarlet witch and then there's nightmare
the original doctor strange villain who
rules the nightmare realm and feeds off
the fear of mortal sleepers in the
trailer doctor strange says that he is
having the same dream every night and
original director scott derrickson was
very interested in including nightmare
in the story going forward despite
rewrites and reshoots it's possible that
some raimi kept nightmare as a central
villain when he took over on multiverse
of madness
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]